I think,
uh,
the great driver of all of these
participatory changes is the choice by
individuals to be active instead of
passive.
Uh,
we fed ourselves on a notion that humans
were office drones at work and couch
potatoes at home and it was just kind of
shuttling back and forth from one to the
other and then when the opportunity to
participate came about even in know,
even in relatively small ways,
right.
I,
I'm going to be sharing photos of this
thing or I'm,
you know,
I wrote a poem and I'm going to put it
up on my blog and maybe only three
people read it,
but that's more than none a that,
that almost all of that is personal
drive,
right?
That's the big,
that's the big producer of the change.
And the individual participants are the
beneficiaries,
right?
The,
the,
the choice to be active benefits.
The person who makes that choice,
uh,
the,
the beneficiaries dance stream of that
is,
I,
you know,
as,
as we talked about earlier,
a really depends on what kind of sharing
is being done.
So if I make a new law cat run,
I find the cutest picture ever and I
give it the funniest caption ever.
It makes some people laugh,
right?
You can't claim a big social benefit
there.
Um,
if at the other extreme I'm at patients
like me and I'm trying to change a,
I'm trying to change medical research
culture,
I might get a disease,
uh,
understood and a cure developed faster
and that benefits not only everyone who
has the disease at benefit society as a
whole for having fewer resources go
into,
go into treatment of,
of,
of whatever disease.
It is a,
there's a lot of work recently on als.
And so once you get past an individual
who chooses to be active getting
benefits for themselves,
you really have to look at what the
participation is doing to see who
benefits,
but the range of benefits that are
possible from harnessing this cognitive
surplus is quite extraordinary.
I say it's bad when it becomes
addictive,
right?
And there's a big,
there's a big discussion about,
uh,
whether or not the word addiction is an
appropriate inappropriate words,
large.
A large clinical conversation about
Internet addiction,
et Al,
but I will tell you that in the early
nineties I felt it.
I used the word addict to describe
myself in a completely,
in a completely unironically.
I was addicted to something called
Usenet,
which is the global set of both boards.
And I had to addicts,
classic pathology,
which is that I needed to,
to be on using it every day.
Not because it made me happy,
but after a while because if I didn't do
it,
it made me feel bad.
Right.
Which is the,
you know,
and our,
I remember literally,
I remember the morning where I woke up
and I did not need to check my email and
I thought,
oh,
it was as if a fever had broke.
Uh,
the,
the deeply wired pleasures of social
interaction coupled with the kind of
mediated space we live in a can create a
can create these kinds of addictions and
people,
whether it's updating their,
updating their profile page on a social
network or it's playing a game or what
have you.
And it can lead people to do many of the
things that the pathology of addiction
does,
which is to cut themselves off from
their friends,
to neglect their social life,
neglect their schoolwork,
neglect their work and so forth.
And those are the kinds of things that
society has always grappled with,
right?
It's,
you know,
it's the problem around a gambler's
anonymous,
right where it's,
it's not that you're injecting a
chemical into your body,
not like alcoholism or,
or,
or cocaine or what have you,
but it is,
it is an activity that's changing the,
you know,
that it's giving you the endorphin rush
or giving you the chemical,
a chemical consistency like in your
brain.
And as with gambling,
there are kinds of activities that can
become addicting.
Uh,
my,
my personal guess,
although I am not a clinician,
my personal guess is that Internet
addiction and even more than the
Internet addiction,
particular classes of addiction,
social gaming addiction,
social network addiction,
so forth are going to be understood
better in the next five years.
They'll turn out to be much rarer than
the hand wringing in the press would
currently.
We currently have you believe where
everyone who uses facebook is a,
is an addict or a punitive addict,
but they will be a nontrivial number of
cases where people are genuinely
addicted.
And I think as a society will then have
to find ways,
uh,
to convince those people to help them
out of that addiction.
In the same way we have done with
gambling is gambling and spread outside
of Vegas to include most of the country.